hey everyone welcome back to another
workout session
today's workout is a compound circuit
focusing on
your upper body as well as your core
strength
before we get started i want you to make
sure that you're bracing your core
throughout the workout
what does it mean to brace your core
that means squeezing and engaging your
abdominal muscles
and also to make sure that your posture
is up right throughout the workout
so no slouching or hunching okay now
imagine this situation
if someone would punch you right in the
stomach and you're not ready
it's gonna hurt correct but if you were
to brace your core and squeeze your abs
if someone were to punch you it's gonna
hurt less
because your core is rock solid the same
thing goes with if someone were to push
you and you're not ready
you're going to fall but if you're ready
you're going to be able to maintain your
balance
and posture so remember to breathe your
core throughout the workout
let's get started
[Music]
there will be a total of three circuits
each workout will be for 45 seconds long
with 15 seconds rest in between
and you'll need one pair of medium
weight dumbbells okay
so let's start with a quick warm-up
because it's going to be an
upper body workout i want you to just
loosen up the joints of your upper body
so in an l straight position without any
weights just squeeze
and open up okay bring your elbows
together
and spread it really feel the stretch
on your upper back as well as your
shoulders
okay elbows touching and open up
good feel more and now
with this position let's just bring your
palms down
and up so it's an l rotation again
we want to warm up the joints on our
shoulders because we're going to be
doing a lot of work on our shoulders so
up and down
just up and down maintaining this
position do not
drop your arms okay and now just press
up imagining that you're doing a
shoulder press
up and down up and down
good now let's combine it l rotation
with a press
l rotation with a press just to warm up
the joints and one more l rotation
with a press good now let's just get
into a squat
and a twist okay remember what i said in
the beginning of the video
brace your car so engage those core
muscles
squeeze your abs as you come up and try
to get
your knee to reach your elbow
and squat deeper good twist
and reach push your butt back
and reach last two more
on each side up and down
one more and good
okay now i want you to step in a wide
sumo squat position
with the toes pointed out let's get into
a squat turn the opposite side
to a lunge okay squat the other way
lunge still warming up our hips
our legs and really
just opening up this part
twist squat push it back
down squat down feel the stretch on the
inner thighs
down and up good
last one more the other side
and come back up okay few hip rotations
and we're ready to start our first
circuit so push your hips forward and
back
and now the opposite side really push
your hips forward
all the way back and
good all right for the first circuit
you'll need a medium weight
dumbbells choose a weight which you know
you can use it throughout the entire
workout
so i would say between three to five
kilos each okay the first workout is
going to be a squat
and a press what i want to do is stand
shoulder-width apart with the toes
pointer forward
have the dumbbells facing forward squat
down as you come up
press straight up okay so your palms
should be
facing in down
all the way up because this is a
compound circuit
it's going to work on your total body
but with the focus
on your upper body as well as core okay
squat is a great workout because it
really engages the core
in order to keep your body upright push
your butt back
as you come up push the dumbbell
straight up down
nice and strong push up
good point your elbows forward
last two more press it up back
down up last one more
and up all right drop the dumbbells
the second workout is going to be a
lunge and a twist
so let's do it without any dumbbells to
begin with really engage your core
what i'm going to do is take a step
forward step back as you step back
twist to the opposite direction forward
back
and twist so twist towards the direction
where your leg is bent twist
it's all about core engagement twist
good now let's add in an extra movement
so twist reach your arms out back in
reach your arms out and twist okay back
in
and out good so i want you to engage
your shoulder muscles as well back out
in and for the second set
we'll be lifting the weights twist
and back up down and twist
up down and twist okay
ab workout let's get down onto the floor
for
the tax all right so point your toes
forward
support your upper body with your palms
fingers pointed forward
let's go keep a leg straight up and down
beginners if this is too difficult you
can choose to bend your knees
straighten it crunch it in and extend it
out
okay for a harder version crunch toe
spinner forward
crunch up good remember that
your upper body should not be doing the
work
it's all about engaging your core
muscles your lower abs your upper abs
and lift your legs up
very nice straight up down
feel your legs shaking feel your entire
body shaking
that's what we want last few more up
back down
up and down whoo
and get back up okay
it's back to the first workout okay
squat
with shoulder press so stand shoulder
width apart
toes pointer forward dumbbells just
directly in front of you let's go strong
arms
strong shoulders strong core press it
straight up
down as low as you can if you want to
try to get your elbows
to touch your knees if this is too much
then just a regular squat
down and up push it up good
down and press up
nice and controlled so do not rest
the dumbbells on your shoulders okay
good
well done i love
upper body workouts and i think that's
something that
we don't do enough of that's one more
down and up okay drop
one dumbbell all right it's going to be
a lunge with a twist this time we want
to use
the weights again step forward ready
take a lunge back extend your arm twist
good do you feel that challenge it's
going to challenge your balance
hence that's why i said brave your core
twist do not lose
balance twist nice and control back up
extend twist very good
twist the opposite side bring the
dumbbell in
if you want to keep your knees bent
throughout the workout
stay low for an extra challenge
break it in twist the opposite side
in and out it's gonna work
on your front delts as well
and in do you feel your glutes as well
it's a total body
workout all right drop the dumbbell
one final cardio blaster
before we end this circuit skaters okay
so i want you to challenge your cardio
and challenge your balance
let's go hop the opposite side
and reach if this is too difficult take
a step
and take a step okay choose your option
for the extra cardio endurance burst
let's go for a hop as far as you can
and reach
remember body upright do not
drop your shoulders or hunch forward
chest up very good last 15 more seconds
and just pace your breathing
two more
three two
and one okay good news
you're getting a one minute
break and we want to move on to the
second
circuit grab some water and keep
yourself hydrated
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are we ready for the second circuit the
second circuit
is going to challenge your chest and
also back
strength so the first workout is going
to be a push-up and a row
again you'll need your dumbbells so
let's start on our knees okay
two dumbbells one push-up row
left and right on your knees
push up if you want more challenge then
you can go
on your toes so this is for your chest
and this is going to work on your lats
remember keep your butt down your hips
down
do not pike your butt up okay push up
and roll good keep going
this is a challenging workout but it's
extremely
effective bro
down and up try to get your chest
as low towards the floor okay
good second exercise it's going to be a
burp beast
with an upright row so a little bit of
cardio movement
but again with the focus on our
shoulders
all right so both dumbbells burpees up
come up row it up okay back down
push it up come up row
so bring the dumbbells close to your
chest
with your elbows spread out
kick back up row remember that
the dumbbells should not be higher
than your elbows back down kick it out
up good stay strong
strong car get into a plank position
back up and roll good
up just few more one more
and good drop the dumbbells
call workout let's get down onto the
floor
reverse plank with a crunch so i want
you to stay
on your toes okay crunch in
crunch in okay opposite leg
so maintaining the strength from your
arms
as well as your core bring
your knee close to your chest
good it's a challenge
but that's what we want drive it in
and out point your toes lift your hips
up
lift your butt off and crunch
keep going
good point your toes rest on your heels
that's one more and back
up okay it's back to
the first workout i am stressing and i
hope
you are at home as well all right push
up
with a row okay so
what i'm going to do is if you can get
onto your toes
one full push-up dumbbell up
and up so spread your legs apart your
feet apart
to for a better balance crunch it up
down strong chest i know
that most of us hate push-ups but
seriously it is one of the best upper
body
and core workout so if you can try to
fit in
at least 10 push-ups every day roll
down push it up stay strong
this is also going to challenge your
wrist up
and roll that's one more
and row okay
i'll be ready for the burpee challenge
all right
let's get your dumbbells ready ready in
a plank position
let's go up pull it up
back down push it up
roll it up okay bring the dumbbell
towards your upper chest and slowly
lower it back down do not just drop it
lower it back down and
up
good job good work this is a really good
front and rear delt workout up
push it back oh my gosh i am dripping
that's two more at least two more
last one more
and up all right drop the dumbbells
reverse plank okay get onto the floor
this is real man this is going down i am
sweating i can feel my heart rate
pumping let's go
alternate leg
up and down good
crunch it in lift it up try to bring
your knee
close to your chest
one step at a time slowly return
your feet to the starting position
and i always say this but you have to
pace your breathing okay
don't rush through the workout pace your
breathing it's gonna help you
to go further
this is not a sprint all right i want
you to finish this
with me okay good job
come back up back up all right
one minute of cardio blaster it's gonna
be
jumping jacks okay love this workout
hit this workout let's bring our heart
rate up
you can choose the low impact option
or if you're with me let's give it a all
up and out so reach your hands together
toes pointed out keep your knees soft
and let's do this 20 more seconds
to the end of the second circuit
you're with me stay strong
it's gonna be so worth it
tap and reach do not stop right now last
five seconds five
four three two one
high five
that is the end of the second circuit
like always
i'm nice so take a shot one minute
break
[Music]
this is your final circuit if you have a
mat grab
a mat and if you have a light pair of
dumbbells
only one kilo then grab it as well if
not
you can also use any water bottles at
home
so for the final circuit we will be
staying on our mat throughout the entire
workout
the first workout is going to be a plank
to a lateral
raise so plank really challenges your
core strength
as well as your upper body let's start
by getting into a high plank position
what i'm going to do is grab one
dumbbell lift it up
raise it twist it and slowly lower it
back
down so it's all about control it's all
about position
do not rush through the workout twist
engage your obliques and get your core
and up okay
try to straighten your arms do not let
it
wobble around twist drop your hips
up okay rotate your hips
while maintaining the high plank
position so do not take your butt
up or do not dip
your hips that's one more on each side
up back down one more
up and back down okay now let's
lie down on your belly
all right this is going to be a superman
squeeze it's going to work
on your lower back as well as your upper
back and shoulders
i want to keep your feet down squeeze it
up
and squeeze and straighten your arms and
back down
so just keep your thighs on the floor
because i want you to focus on working
your back muscles and your shoulders
down up squeeze good
lift all the way up and squeeze can you
feel it
this is a really good workout even
without any
weights extend squeeze
feel the squeeze on your legs your
rhomboids and back
down squeeze good keep your belly
engaged to the floor let's feel more
up remember to maintain a neutral neck
all right good one more core workout
plank up down okay so start
in a high plank position remember to
brace your core
keep your back flat throughout and now
drop one hand down
the other side and push yourself back up
alternating between left and right so
there should be minimal movement
coming from your hips drop it down
and up feel the work on
your arms your shoulders and
your core really engage
and squeeze your abdominal muscles push
it up
your deep abdominal muscles okay and
back up
you should not be rotating your hips
this way this is wrong okay
push it up back down
up down that's two more
stay strong stay with me that's one more
and rest all right
back to the starting of the final
circuit
grab your dumbbells
alright this is going to be a plank with
a lateral raise okay
high plank grab it raise it up to the
side
high up balance twist
good and slowly with control
lower the dumbbells down nice
twist and up
good oh my shoulders
are absolutely burning
and that is what we want okay you want
to be
rocking those sexy shoulders
in your sleeveless tops up
back down bring it up
down that's one more
and down okay push the dumbbells aside
if you have a light pair of dumbbells
i'm only using one kilos
let's add a little bit of challenge and
use this
it's gonna really burn i promise you
okay grab it extend
up squeeze back down
up and squeeze and back down
just that a little bit of additional
weight
i can already feel it squeeze lift your
shoulders off the floor and squeeze
extend and down stay with me
keep your hips down keep your legs down
just focusing on your back
shoulders and abs up
squeeze extend and down
let me know in the comments below if
this workout is a killer
oh absolutely dying and
back down okay all right
final plank workout okay it's gonna be
plank up down okay guys
you got this only two minutes left to
the end
of your workout let's go high plank
lower yourself down
push yourself back up down and
opposite side so alternating
between hands nice and control
do not just collapse
push okay making sure that your arm
is in a straight line with your
shoulders
so arms should be directly underneath
your shoulders not too far forward
and up good raise your core
minimal movements from the hips push it
up
last few more that's one more
it's raining in here and back
down all right you know the drill
one minute of cardio blaster
let's do this it's going to be a plank
jack
okay let's give me all your effort
let's go out and in out and in
push it out and in beginners you can
take a step out
and in okay choose your option
keep going
and breathe strong upper body
and same thing do not pike your butt up
maintain the high plank position
last 15 seconds push into the ground
let's go
last five more seconds five
four three two one
two more one and two
oh my gosh
if you are sweating like me well done to
you
great effort let's get into a child's
pose
and just bring our heart rate down
all right
wipe your sweat if you need to
absolutely drenched
okay before you go anywhere
let's end with a quick cooldown you can
stay on your knees if you want to
let's really stretch out our upper body
okay
so just rotate your shoulders
back loosen up the joints
you have worked really hard on your
upper body today
forward bring your
elbows forward and now let's just
stretch your shoulders right arm across
and just pull it in good holy there
you're at the end of your workout you're
not rushing to go anywhere so just
take this time to bring your heart rate
back down and feel the stretch
lengthen your muscles extend release
and the opposite side
okay
and now let's just big
circles back and big circles forward
good and now let's just stretch out our
hip flexors
so right at the edge of your mat take
your left
knee forward and i want you to just push
your body weight
forward into the ground and you should
feel the stretch on your right hip
flexor
okay and now right arm across and just
twist
open up your chest straighten your back
and just feel the stretch
on your back and your hips as well
good look the opposite side
and now release the other side okay so
right leg forward
again drop your body weight forward
and really feel the stretch on your left
hip flexor
and now left arm across right hand
on your waist and just stretch and look
the opposite side
and just release one more
last stretch downward dog
so get into a plank position this time i
want you to push your butt
back push your butt up and really push
your pumps into the floor
and your heels to the floor so
you should really stretch out your
shoulders your back muscles
as well as your calves and hamstrings
and just look directly between your legs
keeping a neutral spine
back into a plank one more last stretch
push it back
good and stay here
and slowly come back down
very very very well done that is the end
of
a compound circuit with a focus on your
upper body as well as
core strength be sure to check out other
workouts on my youtube channel
do hit the subscribe button if you
haven't yet done it and do give this
video a thumbs up
share with your friends get this workout
done do it regularly
for a leaner and toned arms and i will
see you in my next workout
all the best